(whooshing)
(basketball bounces)
- Passion.
- Passionate.
- Hello Believe Nation.
Today we're going to talk
about how you can have passion.
And as always, guys, as
you're watching, if you hear
something that really
inspires you, please leave it
down in the comments below,
put quotes around it as well
so other people can inspired
and when you write it down,
it's much more likely to sink
into yourself as well, enjoy.
(upbeat music)
- I think the most
beautiful part about life is
finding what you love to do
and finding your place in it.
And finding a way to make that a reality,
whether you love to paint
or to make music or to play
sports or ya know, write,
whatever it is that you love to
do in life or whatever it
is that you love to live
or the people you like
to be around and finding
ways to make that a reality,
like I fell in love with
hip hop when I was real little.
And I started writing
raps and making beats.
And I was like this is what I
love to spend my time doing.
I want to find a way
to make that a reality
and get to travel the
world and get to, life the
way I want to and share that with people.
- You went to play music
when you quit school,
you didn't go to become an actor?
- Well, I had already,
I was already, I started
playin' the guitar at the age of 12.
I felt a passion for it
that yeah, it was the
first real passion that I
had and I can safely say
because I feel and I felt
then that the word ambition
has become dirty, ya know.
- Yeah.
- Because ambition
somehow implies that the.
(baby crying)
I know.
(laughing)
I know, I know, cry.
I'll probably be cryin'
in about 10 minutes so.
(laughing)
So ambition was a dirty
word to me because it
felt like you were working for some game
or material or some status
so I literally don't
remember going through
puberty because I locked
myself in a room at the age of 12, 13.
And just played the guitar,
learned things off records
and taught myself how to
play and it was my life.
And it was the only solace,
it was the only sanctuary.
It was the only security,
it was my first love.
- Many people are what
we call managers or CEOs
and today they can spend seven
years in the watch business
and eventually then they
might move and be a CEO
in a car business or in a crystal brand.
These people are clever
and great entrepreneurs
but they are not necessarily deeply
connected forever to one passion.
I am connected just to watches.
I don't, I would never
like to do another job.
Of course, I have other little passions.
I love wine, I love cheese,
I love classic cars.
But I would never transform
them in a business
because my passion is not deep enough.
While watches is my life.
If I have to die, I want
people to remember two things.
I want my children and my
wife to remember my love
and I want people to remember my
contribution to the watch business.
So that's really my
objective, that's why I would
never leave this business and not many.
I have been in the business
since '74 so it's nearly
40 years, 39 years in the
same business and I don't know
many people in this business
that have been 39 years there.
Some great people came but
they came from a car brand,
came from Ferrari or from
Maserati and joined the watch
business and they've been seven years.
They going to move and
go to Hermes or Veto.
So it's different, I am a
watch fan, a watch freak.
- People won't know what
I went through between
the second and third
album, of the fear that was
implemented in me, even
though I knew I was talented.
I have to be confident in what I do.
And that song was one of the
first songs that I recorded
for the album and I was
actually going to call the album
Masterpiece and I just thought
no, it doesn't make sense.
If people hear it on
its own, it just sounds
like I'm bein' an absolute asshole.
But for me, I've never made it.
I've never finished my paintin'.
Until the day that my eyes
close and I don't wake up,
I feel like I'm still puttin'
towards my masterpiece.
And I want to work hard and I'm
okay to say, hey, I messed up.
I do things, I say things,
I wear things, I date people
I shouldn't, I'm human and
we're all building on something
that we hope can leave a
standing of the test of time.
And I think that that's
what that song means to me
and I, I really, really put
it towards the other people
that have gone, you can't
do this or lied about me
and said I'm difficult or
this and that and called me a
diva and when I'm not, I'm passionate.
No, there's a very, very
thin, when people can't deal
with how passionate you
are, they attack you.
And that's the same with anyone.
- Because everybody kept asking
me, what does it feel like,
what does it feel like,
when you got the nomination,
that little girl from
Washington DC, what did
it feel like when you heard your name?
- Mine was a roller coaster ride.
I was nominated for this
and wasn't for that.
So I really put it out
of my head 'cause I don't
really do what I do for the awards.
Like you said, if you're
passionate about your work,
all the accolades will come.
You got to stay focused on what
God put you on Earth to do.
So that's number one.
(applause)
- Yeah, I mean, I was very fortunate.
I started trying to work at 14
and I got on a sit com when I was 16.
I dealt with a lot of
no's, mostly personal no's,
within my family, it's
hard for a 14 year old
to say, I'm leaving Kentucky,
I'm moving to New York.
But I knew, I felt so
strongly, it feels insane
to be a teenager and know,
I knew that it was the
right thing to do, I knew
it was going to work out.
- Were they supportive, your family?
- Well no, I wouldn't be
supportive if my teenager
was like, I'm movin' to New York.
They thought, ya know, they
thought I was going to get killed.
I'm surprised I didn't get
killed but it was like this
fire and also this like, I just knew it.
So I eventually saved up babysitting money
and went and did it.
- What about the business
of being what you are now,
the musician, the
songwriter, I mean, did you
display an early talent for singing?
- I didn't actually, I got
thrown out of the choir.
- [Interviewer] Did you?
(laughing)
- I was thrown out of
the choir for, I think,
as far as I know, it was for talking.
And I always remember my
dad used to say to me,
'cause I used to say, Dad,
that when I was like 16, 17, 18
and my dad was threatening
to throw me out of the house
if I didn't get a job within
a certain amount of time
so obviously I went out
and got jobs but I was
saying, I want to be a singer,
I think I'm going to be
rich and famous and he would
say, everybody wants to be
a pop singer, everybody wants.
And I would say no Dad,
everybody wants to be
a pop singer when they're
12, ya know, when they're 12.
I've, this is my whole life,
this is what I want to do.
But I've lost my train of thought.
(laughing)
- Was it to be rich and
famous, your ambition,
I mean, was that it?
- No.
I think I had two very,
very strong ambitions
and they've always fought
against one another, always.
And one was a passion for
music and an ability to
communicate through music
and really a sense of purpose
through music and two
was this desire to be
and rich and famous is not
right because actually,
rich never came into it,
I actually realized about
six months ago, someone
put a question to me
and I actually realized
that at no point during
my early life when I
was, in all my ambitions
or even when I started
to realize my ambitions,
at no point did it ever
occur to me that one of the
byproducts of this would be
that I could buy whatever I
wanted or live in a big
house, have a flashy car,
all the things that are very pleasant.
But it really hadn't occurred
to me, it never occurred to
me so I didn't want to be rich, I
just wanted to be filthily famous.
(downbeat music)
(screaming)
- [Interviewer] What did
Cronos achieve for you?
- Well, that movie changed
my life because we were
more than the underdog,
more than the dark horse.
We were a movie that
nobody wanted to produce,
nobody was supporting except
my producers in Mexico.
And we suddenly were selected
for CAN and literally,
we were all of the sudden
one of the most awarded
movies in Mexican Film History.
I remember the first time
Cronos won the first award
which was a cash award
and before that award,
we were in debt for half a million.
We won the award and literally
like a beauty contest,
I was crying, crying in
the stage holding this
giant check and I was trembling
and I was really moved
because a, I was happy the
movie was being recognized
and b, I was not going to jail.
- I watched so many Metros
in my life, unbelievable
and really not so, some
boring games and then I sleep.
And it's so boring, why
they beat each other
and make this 20, 40,
50, 60, 70, 80,000 people
in a stadium with this
boring game, it's not okay.
So that's what we want to
see, we want to enjoy our own
game, if we lose, okay, we like to win.
But if we lose with our way, it's okay.
If we lose with the way of somebody else,
it's, you cannot work
with this so that's it.
It's very emotional,
very fast, very strong,
not boring, no chess, like this.
Yeah, of course, tactical
but with big heart
and tactical things are so important.
You cannot win without tactical things
but the emotion make the difference.
Life in our game, that's important.
- Well, I've always played the violin.
Ever since I was six years
old, I begged for lessons.
And I've always played and
it was actually when I was in
college that I kind of just
realized one day that I didn't
love it anymore and I used to love it.
And I specifically didn't
study music in school
because I didn't ever want
to have the love of my
music be out of me so it
kind of broke my heart
when I was like, I don't
even enjoy this anymore.
And so I started thinking,
okay, what can I do
to like invigorate my passion,
like I started playing
with bands, I started just
anywhere I could go to kind of
try out new styles of
music and I've always loved
electronic music and
it just hit me one day.
I need to play and write the kind
of music that I am loving right now.
(funky music)
And so I did and it just
brought it back to life for me.
It made it so creative
and I became a creator,
not just a musician and
that's, I think, what
just invigorated my passion.
- So thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know what did
you think of this video.
What clip resonated the
most with you that you're
going to take and immediately
apply to your life
or your business somehow,
leave it down in the comments
below and I'm going to
join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Karim Al-Kassem.
Thank you so much Karim
for picking up a copy of my
book, Your One Word, it
really, really, really
means a lot to me and I
hope you're enjoying it.
So thank you guys, again, for watching.
I believe in you, I hope
you continue to believe
in yourself and whatever
your One Word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.
(whooshing)
(basketball bounces)